on le dit petit rondouillard et chaud
mais c'est un acteur splendide monsieur
tout le monde ait du talent comme
personne gérard jugnot
gérard jugnot bonsoir soit on va se
livrer une petite interview première
fois c'est vous voulez bien
la première baffe c'est pas la première
mais j'aime bien et dont je me souviens
c'est quand j'ai fait une blague à mon
père qui venait de changer la moquette
il avait acheté une moquette tout neuf
c'est une grande grande première et
j'avais acheté une fausse une fausse
tâche d'encre une petite bouteille
d'encre c'est quand mon père a vu ça je
suis pris une terrible famine ramos
était pas c'est resté très secret la
passion c'était la planète elle jamais
su trop quand même on le sait toujours
pas et c'était à royan j'avais fait les
plans de tout temps toute la côte
sauvage
ça m'occupe est pour savoir si je
l'emmenais où j'aurais pu l'emmener pour
embrasser en cachette sans que ça
paraisse fait toute une topographie des
lieux conçus jamais serré première
expérience sexuelle
c'était en tunisie on a un club de
vacances qui n'était même pas
méditerranéen
les jeunes filles que j'ai forcément
avoir très envie mais j'ai tellement
tanné
mitchell a accepté gentiment premier
pétard j'ai un souvenir vraiment ils
m'ont fait fumer du shit avec lhermitte
et clavier on a été aux états unis est
en fait tiré là dessus c'est une herbe
très forte
ça devait être un des premiers froids
c'était un des derniers parce que j'ai
une seconde à lui et c'était à saint
louis missouri joue souvent et d'un seul
coup j'ai vu tous les mecs sortir des
bosquets avec des fusils à canon scié et
plus enrayer un reee est plurielle thèse
non c'est vrai ça et j'ai eu une vraie
panique donc
non c'est pas mon truc sa première
expérience homosexuelle
on se tripoter dans les chiottes au
lycée mais bon c'était pas très vraiment
homosexuels c'était un très bon contre
un défi jamais pénétration première
faille à la paix qui n'est plus moi plus
importante c'est une paye de figuration
qui était la marque artistes de
complément ça à mon père est tombé à la
renverse arty de complément c'était pour
lui atroce considérer que je n'étais
même pas un artiste complet - comme
premiers millions d'anciens francs
je suis pas encore je vais partir du
premier procès d'un penser que j'ai fait
pour contre mon sosie
inutilisé mon image des femmes peu
commercial qui me déplaisait au revoir